you
hi everyone is Jerry let's have a look
at a game that was played in Sweden 1955
at the Gothenburg inter-zonal on the
white end the greatest own Ian player
Paul Karras he is the one player who has
defeated more world champions than
anyone else nine in total and he has
finished second in five candidates
tournaments these details about him are
what has given him the nickname the
uncrowned King his opponent the 10th
world champion Boris Spassky let's have
a look at this one where we're working
with a Queen's Indian defense and when I
hear the name Queen's Indian defense
there's one square that kind of sticks
out to me and that is the e4 square
there's a fight over that point black
does not want to see a pawn trio and
will be directing some pieces there now
I like White's approach in this game
namely to deploy the King side before
the Queen side and there's good reason
for this one of the key defenders of the
e4 square will be the Queen Knight
however deploying the Queen Knight a bit
too early subjects it to a pin and well
the bishop can then knock out that key
defender therefore we have first III
Bishop d3 castles and now white will
feel a bit more confident deploying the
Knight to c3
have there been Bishop to b4 along the
way white always had the option to block
with a piece that would never have the
potential to control this important
efore square okay from here both Kings
are now tucked away queen Bishop has to
do something so be three Knights are
connected for black Queen Knight goes to
c3 here and c5 so nine moves in I'm
throwing a pop quiz your way that's not
the typical kind is there anything
interesting that you note about this
position right here anything kind of
stick out to you feel free to pause the
video
okay the thing that draws my attention
is the great symmetry in this position
aside from the Queen Knights and the
King bishops everything else is the same
how does this factor into this position
well for starters move ten we can find
that the White Queen finds a very nice
home on e - that's pretty cozy why do I
say this well black on the other hand
well first of all black can't do similar
right black doesn't have the
corresponding e 7 square available for
the Queen so where will the black Queen
go will the black Queen feel comfortable
being on the C and D files when these
pawns are volatile and the C and D files
are therefore subject to change half
open open completely open who knows how
it's going to change black needs to take
a little bit of care here so for example
if black says I want to deploy my queen
as well let's play to c7 you'll notice
that white can take and then play rook a
to c1 and the Queen starts to feel some
pressure right that's an uneasy square
not stable what is black do then
well initiates a capture on c4 and waits
to see how white recaptures towards the
center with a pond or taking with a
piece and go from there well let's put
the move on the board white elects a
pawn recapture so now the black Queen
feels much more confident about playing
to c7 because the C pawn lacks the
ability to make a capture and open up
the C file okay from here the rook is
supporting a d5 advance indirectly black
is there as well and d5 hits so from
here we have a six a small move but it's
actually packing a a punch if white
isn't careful the best continuation
instead of a six is considered
to go in for these captures here and
allow this little tactic on h7 where we
reach a position where the material is
balanced but the position is very much
imbalanced structurally three to one for
black on the Queen side and not the
coziest blanket for the black king
just a couple pawns and yeah it's
possibilities for pieces maybe drifting
out there towards the Kings side at some
stage all of them are really pointing
towards the Kings side but still in the
computer's eyes this is considered best
this position by the way is reminding me
of the double bishops sacrifice game
anyhow this isn't the direction
Spassky goes in ego plays a6 so what is
this little idea behind a six
if white makes a flight square here this
is the idea this is how quickly things
can change in this position after the
structure changes like this White has a
two to zero majority in the center hang
on we're seeing the point of a6 b5 is in
and who knows what's going to happen
next these pieces start to feel a little
bit uneasy and they could be kicked at
any moment Queen side pawns get rolling
fast white understands this is not going
to allow this capture recapture b5 and
cetera so white takes on e6
it's a weakness in blacks camp II 6 and
sure enough pinpoints it Knight g5 Queen
c6 is not only defending but game over
on g2 how to defend here the main threat
feel free to pause the video what would
you do
okay in the game F for multi-purpose
lateral defense and it secures an
important square on e5 rules out that
night jump
continuing the night is given a kick
returns to f4 and let's draw some
attention here to the structures black
has a majority on the queenside white on
the kingside what is Queen to c7 doing
it's preventing white from advancing the
majority of these four pawns the the two
that really want to move are the E and F
pawns these guys are going to stick
around to be the kings blanket white
wants to get an e for this move right
here so what is Queen c7 doing saying
not so fast that would drop the f4 pawn
so Queen c7 prevents the majority from
rolling this Knight is getting a bit of
a workout he is now eyeing up a weak
Square g6 couple pieces of observing
this nice weak square on g6 little
reposition time Bishop backing up out of
the rooks way who knows maybe a nice
little battery if there isn't a secure
piece that's that's going to watch over
h7 so rook here on e 8 is opening up a
nice square for the knight to defend the
weak squares Queen f2 we do have these
two bishops bearing down towards the
black King and white is trying to add an
additional ingredient to this attack
Queen on g3 connects really well with
the bishops Knight f8 Queen g3 black has
some nice coordination here this is a
close to a pawn advantage for WIPO you
know black is still in the ball game for
sure in this position
from here Knight h6 Queen h3 and the
knight returns you'll notice that black
kind of lost time here these last two
moves is it really better is it really a
good idea for black to have played
Knight H 5 + f6 just to have the Queen
on H 3 instead of G 3 it is White's move
once more the computer is actually
preferring instead of this little back
and forth stuff to advance the majority
on the Queen side one of the suggestions
here is to play Bishop c6 with a knife
with an eye out for b5 okay well in the
game we have this little back and forth
Queen on h3 and from here the knight
jumps in be five and the one square that
has just been given up or the big square
that has been given up d5 is immediately
made use of this was no this has been
you know for as long as the knight and
Bishop have remained like this this is
always something you really look forward
to doing right improve to pieces in just
one move ninety five bishops seeing the
world the knight hasn't been improved
okay he's taken out white doesn't
recapture on d5 that was considered best
but this is also good as well capturing
on e5 may be part of the reasoning that
goes into this is to ensure that this F
file is ripped open
both white rooks are now functioning
from here Bishop takes e5 Knight takes
e5 Bishop e6 Queen g3 this is this is
roughly equal in this position I like
White's position a little bit better
because of the bishop pair and they're
both doing a pretty good job right
pointing at the black King one roof
off-black gets rolling on the Queen side
and after rook to f1 this game is very
close to ending actually a sudden end to
this game we only see a move 30 this is
a roughly equal position just a tiny bit
better for Team white suggestion by the
engine is to play Knight here slight
improvement for this for this piece
eyeing up the g5 square but Spassky goes
way wrong in this position playing
Knight off to d7 just trying to
challenge the strongly placed White
Knight and this next move by Paul Karras
must have come as a great shock to
Spassky because after the move is on
board
Spassky resigns what is that move what
did team white play here feel free to
pause the video ok the game-winning shot
Queen takes g7 this is a beautiful
tactic
Spassky resigned here if King takes
Queen they would follow Knight takes
Knight and now okay Queen blocks you
just take the Queen the King has to go
back to g8 look at all the ground these
bishops are covering along with the rook
and g8 is the only safe Square like it
then follow up with Knight f6 forcing
the King to one of these three squares
in regardless of which one he goes to
there will be a discovered check next so
this would be worst of all g7 because of
a double check and there goes the Queen
vest in this position would be king f7
but in this case white would still come
out on top with Knight d5 discovered
check and then you simply pick up the
Queen after the smoke has cleared white
is now simply up a minor piece and still
giving some direction to team black this
would be the best black could do after
this shot on g7 Spassky understood that
that was on its way this sequence and he
was going to be down a piece throws in
the towel at this stage after 30 moves
so a very nice game by the great Paul
carries the uncrowned King feel free as
usual to leave any feedback to this
video in the comment section below hope
you enjoyed it maybe took a thing or two
away from it that's all for now take
care bye
you